Magnus with black has a neck yeah okay
some pawns are running Queen on
eight and the C3 Knight is hanging C3
Knight is hanging with a check G1 quick
Queen C3 check
I mean certain Magnus is not winning
oh wait 25 Queen D5 eliminating the last
Pawn we need three
wait a second could he
I think he could win by exchanging and
going B5 but it's it's already gone yeah
he's three seconds look at this his last
move was made on one second
grigo roundsmith yep yeah before checks
and Magnus is fighting for a draw now
okay just go B6 don't lose on time I
have already lost a game to Sergey in
this queen end game to be and to be
honest but it must be 10 seconds
increment okay check and then Pawn goes
to B7 and then let's see how much of an
expert you know those ending endings
Magnus Carson is
check and you have to give
I mean you have to give proper checks
oh no I think the key should be not fed
on G1 right
whoops Queen H again move with one
second Queen H4 but a very strong one 23
Queen G3 and he win now wow Magnus Bravo
denied
[Music]